if we said today we're going back to LA
tomorrow does Benjy make the cut to go
no no Gary Gary yes I worked really hard
on her I didn't want I did too
yeah really hard yeah yeah well I did I
think I get frustrated about is because
he is very talented and he is very funny
and you know if he really did try or
apply himself it'd be amazing we know
we've seen him do work in the past where
he was really amazing and it's like
you're kind of half in half out all
right we're done now we're done good
enough all right every day I worked out
there right hmm all right yes you did
something but almost as much work was
put into producing you as was put into
producing the whole rest of the show
right usually that's what you're missing
you're supposed to make things easier
not harder
people are looking for complaints about
mythologies nobody's ever complained
that was not a lie and that all came
back to your diet I want some sort of
pasta I want some sort of vegetable and
no cheese is that why six minutes take
you six minutes to order I didn't yes I
said to the waiter I'd like a pasta with
vegetables without cheese without farms
that's what I said say it like but he
did not say it like you know you didn't
say it like I did say always and they
had to bring over his second waiter
[ __ ] as I said but you have two
eyewitnesses saying it's true
go talk to her son all right all right
where's your own personal get him waiter
okay
in another waiter I timed him and I
showed crispy timing him just to make
sure that this didn't happen all right
one of those projections
just sayin at the table in LA another
example of Benjy just being a [ __ ]
pain in the ass right they had a timer
on it he had his own waiter there to
bring over a second waiter it was six
minutes of Benjy exhaustively going
through he wants pasta no cheese no
cheese pasta pasta and and he's looking
at the menu he's asking questions and no
cheese I got to the dinner a couple of
minutes later than everyone and they sat
me at Benji's table right and what I
said on wrap-up was maybe some of that
happened before I got there cuz when I
got there everyone already had their
menus oh but when I was there I do not
recall Benjy taking six minutes to order
I remember the the waiter came over and
everything happened pretty cool I'm just
saying that was the second waiter was
there a waiter before respond got there
that came over and helped you perhaps a
waiter they handed out mater went mad
and wanted ordered before alright so I
got there and you got into it I got a
move on you disappointed you were
sitting at Benji's table seriously no I
actually enjoyed talking to Benjy I was
disappointed with how the checks check
out I thought that whole situation
turned into a mess